d'être ensemble et à sa femme elle va
absolument faire rencontrer du coup sa
famille à son chéri donc elle lui dit
écoute je vais organiser un repas il va
avoir tout le monde l'attente l'oncle
mes parents la grand-mère
l'arrière-grand-mère le chien et là
il est pas bien parce qu'en fait il
explique que quand il a un rendez-vous
il est stressé et quand il est stressé
mais il a des gaz il pète il pète il
pète du coup elle lui dit écoute
t'inquiète pas chérie je sais ton
problème mais j'ai vu avec le docteur on
va prendre une capsule et à chaque fois
t'inquiète pas pendant le repas tu
pourras prendre cette capsule il
t'arrive à rien t'inquiète pas 30
minutes avant tu auras plus rien ok ça
va je prends la capsule tout va bien il
arrive l'entrée il commence à parler
avec tout le monde ça se passe bien
arrive le plat et là comment ça avoir
mal au ventre il est pas bien il a les
sueurs et il lâche une caisse énorme oh
comment il va faire et tout l'arrière
grand-mère qui regarde le chat et dehors
attention Médor OK
il continue le plat et continue le plat
l'entrée le dessert et là d'un coup il
continue
dehors attention là il se dit bon ben
c'est bon bingo l'arrière-grand-mère
elle y voit rien elle pense que c'est le
chien je vais pouvoir me lâcher et puis
surtout j'arrive plus à me retenir
j'arrive plus à m'asseoir et tout c'est
très compliqué j'arrive à tenir de
discussion je lâche la dernière caisse
alors ça c'est la caisse de l'année ça
pète ça pète fort et là elle a rien
quand même le chien lui dit attention
Médor je t'avais prévenu à force il va
te Chier dessus
[Applaudissements]
ça se passe dans un mariage il y a la
mariée qui arrive et mecs ils se
retourne il prend la comment elle
éclater la mariée elle a une personne
qui dit non je vous dérange pas je vous
parlais de ma fille là déjà pardon je
savais pas que vous étiez son père je
sais pas son père je suis sa mère
[Applaudissements]
parce que sinon vous baissez la tranche
de Gladys tout simplement régime c'est
une tranche ABC qui merci Jean-Marie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est quoi pour ceux qui
connaissent pas
de boutiques de luxe c'est certainement
la place d'ailleurs la plus luxueuse de
Paris et voilà il y a un camion noir 6
heures du matin carré il se gare devant
la vitrine de chez Cartier le hayon
s'ouvre l'éléphant énorme un éléphant
décent attends Jean-Marie on va la
refaire parce qu'il y avait un problème
tu as déjà perdu ta mère
[Applaudissements]
l'éléphant fonce dans la vitrine de chez
Cartier il est casse la vitrine bien sûr
avec sa trompe et bijoux il remonte et
remonter dans le camion et le le camion
il part le commissaire arrive deux
heures plus tard et il dit au seul
témoin de la faire c'est un petit garçon
de café qui installe sa terrasse
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu je raconte il
y a un gros camion noir l'éléphant a
cassé la vitrine elle a piqué bijoux en
montant le camion le camion est parti
et le commissaire il dit vous avez le
l'immatriculation du camion vous avez
noté
c'est une blague ou quoi
dis comment on dit j'assiste à un truc
complètement dingue ni vous croyez que
je me suis amusé à regarder la plaque du
camion dis non bien sûr que non moi il
dit le marque du camion non plus bah il
dit bien sûr
non plus qu'est-ce que vous me pétez les
couilles alors là le commissaire
et il lui dit mais dites-moi quand même
monsieur vous pouvez peut-être quand
même me dire si c'était un éléphant
d'Afrique
pour un éléphant d'Asie
de ma gueule
j'habite à Sarcelles moi qu'est-ce que
j'y connais
et là le commissaire lui aussi il est en
colère il vous savez très bien ce que je
veux dire ça va très bien que l'éléphant
d'Afrique il y a des grandes oreilles et
l'éléphant d'Asie il a des petites
oreilles on va dire je peux pas vous
dire il avait une cagoule
[Applaudissements]
alors fini
ça va
[Applaudissements]
la star très très bien
alors merci beaucoup
c'est un humanitaire un Américain et un
prêtre ils sont dans un avion et la
viande est en train de chuter ça va être
une catastrophe terrible l'avion va
s'écraser on le sait et là l'humanitaire
voit un enfant seul sur le siège attaché
qui se tient comme ça il y a un seul
parachute et là l'humanitaire dit oh là
là c'est terrible mais laissons le
parachute à l'enfant là l'Américain fait
non non en fait je Boys et le prêtre a
dit oui mais est-ce qu'on aura le temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
les amis merci on t'aime mon chéri merci
complètement bourré il pose la bouteille
de vodka et il se glisse à côté de sa
femme et une demi-heure après écris je
t'aime
c'est toi qui parle ou c'est la
bouteille de vodka qui parle et c'est
moi qui parle à la bouteille de vodka
[Applaudissements]
nous rappelle 10
c'est le problème librement
le mec rentre librement et il s'est tout
allongé il se couche dans le plumard et
il meurt tu vois aussitôt et là il
arrive vers Saint-Pierre tu vois et donc
Saint-Pierre il lui l'autre il dit il
m'a dit c'est quoi l'histoire je suis
mort c'est ça j'ai bien compris je suis
mort décédé quoi mais dis moi ça veut
dire bah oui monsieur il y a un moment
faut mourir et dit non non il y a pas un
moment moi je veux pas mourir moi moi je
veux retourner sur Terre maintenant très
en colère Saint-Pierre bon et il prend
en compte le Kourou du du mec qui dit
écoutez monsieur c'est pas normal moi je
fais ça depuis des siècles et des
siècles on peut pas revenir comme ça ou
alors
j'aurais bien une solution mais dis quoi
allez-y dis je pourrais vous faire
revenir mais ce serait en animal quoi il
dit oui il dit en ce moment j'ai que
poule
il y a pas d'autres choix c'est pour le
midi je me branle
je reviens en poule il y a pas de
problème je reviens ais je retrouve en
poule
dans la basse-cour
le coq il arrive il vient avant il dit
bonjour madame la poule
aider vous êtes la nouvelle comment ça
va et ben elle dit ça va ça va mais si
je vous disais je me sens un petit peu
barbouillé quoi tu peux j'ai mal au
ventre à coque c'est parce que vous
allez pondre un œuf certainement je suis
un spécialiste vous pouvez me croire et
vous croyez dit oui oui allez-y madame
la poule poussez poussez vous allez
pondre un œuf pour tous ces pousses
qui sort le coq qui dit voyez je vous
l'avais dit c'était un œuf ça va mieux
et la poule elle dit bah ça va mieux ça
va mieux
je suis encore un petit peu
mal au ventre a dit ça c'est un deuxième
œuf
ça arrive des fois par deux et dialyse
pousser madame la poule vous êtes une
poule poussée allez-y
un deuxième œuf qui arrive tu vois hier
à ce moment-là le mec qui prend une
grande tarte dans la gueule par sa femme
lui dit oh c'est pas bien de finir de
chier dans le plumage
c'est la Coupe du Monde des cygnes
un Amérindien très calme cette année
tombe en finale face à un mec allant de
Marseille la finale commence et c'est
parti Geronimo il fait ça à Marseille il
fait ça
Monsieur Alain a gagné bravo quoi ils
vont voir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah
c'est très simple j'ai commencé avec la
force il est venu avec la résistance
j'ai fait l'unité il m'a fait la dualité
je l'ai fait la trilogie il m'a fait le
cobra j'ai pas réparer
je ne pouvais rien faire
et non c'est pas fini
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé c'est très simple il m'a dit
j'arrive pour te frapper j'ai dit chaton
[ __ ] il m'a dit je vais mettre un
doigt dans le cul moi je tombais deux tu
m'as dit moi je te mets un troisième moi
je te mets jusqu'au coude il me dit il y
a pas la plage ne t'inquiète pas on va
faire la place
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup moins bien à la radio elle est
très bonne voilà et bravo
c'est deux potes qui parlent tous les
deux comme ça ils sont tous les deux et
puis il dit à l'autre bah c'est bien tu
as laissé les blondes de côté
je peux la faire revenir après dans
l'histoire on va voir alors c'est un
pote et une blonde qui parle
un petit
virage
attends merci franchement il y a la
pharmacienne à côté ils ont fait un truc
extraordinaire au lieu de payer 30 40
balles chez ton dentiste il y a une
espèce d'ordinateur tu mets tes urines
dedans il te dit exactement ce que c'est
tu vois ok le mec est un peu sceptique
c'est Ricardo tu peux y aller ça va tu
dis que tu viens de Samantha il y a
aucun problème tu as vu l'impro
donc le mec il va tu vois il est un peu
bon il pisse dans le truc il arrive à la
pharmacie ils vont un espèce
d'ordinateur comme ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
il est le papier vous avez une tendinite
au coude
évitez de les charges lourdes et mettez
votre coude dans l'eau chaude très
régulièrement [ __ ] génial truc de fou
tu vois et le mec il est un peu con il
dit waouh ça te fous ça mais alors
attends j'aimerais bien faire une
connerie avec leur dit la machine j'ai
rien tenter un truc tu vois donc il
rentre chez lui tu vois il est un peu un
peu marvalo le gars qu'est-ce qu'il fait
il prend le petit la petite fiole il dit
attends je vais retourner on va faire
une blague mets un petit peu d'eau de
chez lui tu vois un petit peu d'eau du
robinet et il promène son chien comme ça
et c'est un temps j'ai fait un truc tac
il prend la merde de son chien hop il
met un petit peu dedans il touyas
il va voir chérie tu as pas envie de
pisser par hasard ouais monsieur ouais
tiens vas-y mets-moi un petit peu de
pissouille c'est pour un copain machin
là il met un petit peu la pistouille de
sa femme mitoyas il fait pareil que sa
fille ouais chérie un petit peu la
puissance un petit peu la pissage
comme dernier truc à la con comme ça
va dans les chiottes
il se paluchent
et tout Yass son mari dédicace
je vais [ __ ] la machine c'est
obligatoire il va la machine il met sa
petite fiole il met le petit billet de
10 balles tu
[Musique]
fous il est là je préfère le lire parce
que j'ai pas retenu et le ticket sort et
il lit ton eau est dégueulasse achète
ton filtre à eau ton chien des verres
achète lui des vitamines la fille se
drogue à la cocaïne mais là dans un
centre de réhabilitation ta femme est
enceinte de jumeaux ils sont pas toi
prends un bon avocat
et si tu arrêtes pas de te branler ton
coude va jamais guérir
[Applaudissements]